be normal
it will always be the three of us
always
hey Luke big day for you why because you
will get to meet your real mom what we
all made a pact we deny it until you
turn 21 but that's the real reason dad's
old girlfriend's coming over
she's your mom and if she likes you
you'll go live with her I'm not adopted
I'm asking mom you mean Mrs Dunphy she's
not going to tell you the truth
I'm not I know
just because he called you a
door-to-dork Salesman
The Empire Strikes Back
I'm starving me too
um Dad
we haven't had lunch yet neither of half
the kids in Africa stop yapping and get
back to work
I'm not out of my mind
you took advantage and you lost your
computer privileges
either that we cut off all your hair
because that's what caused the problem
thoughts
good because after you finish this room
you're going to clean my bathroom too
and you know how gross I can be
oh my gosh oh my God
all right
settle down it's hair
will you hurry up I'm saving my strength
because if we don't find this helicopter
I'm walking to Canada
I'll be like taxes
hey that's our helicopter is it now I'm
sure you have the proper documentation
for that just just give it back it's
ours those are bullies you can't be
bullies they're nerds don't pigeon all
us we can be both
is there an issue here Uncle cam
I got this
oh my God it's Alex done face oh awesome
problem here boys these Geeks won't give
us back our helicopter that we took from
Reuben is that right Abraham oh my God
she knows your name helicopter please
I love you
what just happened you have your fans I
have mine
someday your fans are going to work for
my fans
oh I'm sorry were you trying to read
you're the one who tries to read oh my
gosh I am not seriously hate when you
think you are the dumbest person
I'm so sick of YouTube fighting all the
time you're a bad big sister and you're
a bad little sister and you're both bad
big sisters to me
be normaler
wow
I've never seen him like that
well we do kind of neglect him
and if you think about it he is kind of
our little sister
remember how we used to dress him up I
miss her I hear you I don't like where
this is going
you get the lipstick I'll get the bronze
tennis balls
Betty Luke I will burn this house down
I hope you're a heavy metal fan because
all the heavy metals are going right
here above your trophy oh hey cool
Maisie so I heard they are giving out
mailbox keys downstairs and I was
thinking maybe you could pick up both of
ours sure thing friend what a day I've
got a mailbox and a friend and a friend
you sure do could you try not to enjoy
this so much this is me trying this ends
now what are you doing what do you think
I'm doing I'm getting rid of her I'm
calling my advisor and getting a new
roommate
hey don't give Dad back need I remind
you I am a yellow belt no I can't keep
track of all your ugly belts but I don't
think you should change roommates listen
as much as you're my go-to girl on
College advice I really my God would you
just shut up for a second
here's the thing I had a similar
experience with a roommate she was this
annoying little know-it-all who totally
got on my nerves I get it oh shh
I spent a long time trying to get rid of
her until I realized that little girl in
her own way put me on a pedestal it felt
great
you just landed in a world of
superstars and I know you would never
admit it but
you're scared
it's not the worst thing to have your
own personal cheerleader
I miss mine already
well I guess my five seconds is up
good good
uh no velcro our brand is a little more
upscale
oh another buyer is tired of seeing the
same feat oh
is he doing to keep things interesting
surprised you were open to this I'm
surprised you know how to do this
don't forget we have to get over to
Mom's work to ship shoes later wait a
second you're using mom's FedEx every
time she and Dad have fancy night out
she uses the hashtag Luke's college fund
so yeah I'm using her account
oh my God you're cheating no you're
looking at ways to solve the puzzle
how'd you do it you pay brain
what is wrong with me maybe Dr Johnson
is right maybe I don't know what it
takes to live on Mars
stop stop it's not you after I solved
the puzzle I wanted to make sure you
couldn't so I broke a few pieces glued
some others together it can't be solved
it what the hell break it up Luke's not
playing Fair yeah will you make him feel
dumb and he acts like it doesn't bother
him but it does and Luke you know better
than to mess with someone so uptight
what do we always say don't break Alex
she's our safety net now you both need
to calm down look what
the doll who cares
Haley what's going on with you today are
you okay
okay
um
so no one else knows especially mom and
dad so you can't tell anybody but
pregnant
what
guys don't look at me like that okay you
must think I'm some irresponsible idiot
don't you
um uh it's a wow that's you got that's a
lot to process like
do you know who's the it's Dylan's oh
what a joyous oh save it he's been great
actually I'm the disaster we look at
Lulu
[Music]
okay first it's just a doll
and you've been taking care of us our
whole lives yeah remember how you used
to pick out my first day of school
outfit so I wouldn't get beat up or how
you told the book while I read myself a
bedtime story and you're still doing it
you just swooped in and handled our
fight like a pro and your understanding
and loving and a total badass she's
right
you're the kind of person that could
patch things up if say
Alex ever found out that I rearranged
her stickers on a Rubik's Cube you son
of a kid uh hair hair Haley help hi
Mommy and Daddy we know you don't think
that we can take care of a dog but you
haven't met our dog Wolfie no barking
Wolfie but you just said to bad dog
oh no and don't worry we'll always
remember to feed him and keep him
healthy is there a pill in here so you
don't want a shiny coat you guys are
probably worried he's going to get the
house all dirty well we know how to
handle that wait how are we gonna drop
so as you can see we can do this we know
a dog's a lot of work
yeah it will always be the three of us
always
the end
you guys know you can call me anytime
right
and it's easy to visit Switzerland so
and I can still count on you for
relationship advice right I don't want
to become one of those pathetic guys
that lets women manipulate them
we're gonna be fine
sit
stay
[Music]
foreign